hi I'm Matt Steiner matt is a senior
crime scene analyst he explained how
crime scenes worked in technique
critique so in this case he uses
deductive reasoning to come up with the
handedness of our victim Louise is a
staff writer at Wired matt is going to
teach Louie is how to lift fingerprints
from different surfaces ranging from
easy ones to difficult ones so I put my
fingerprints on a bunch of stuff where
should we start let's start with
something easy so what do you see here
what should we be thinking about when
we're looking at this Plexiglas the
first thing we want to consider is the
surface itself the most ideal surface
for fingerprints is something that's
smooth and non-porous and that's what we
got here we have Plexiglas it's great
for fingerprints so now we prepare our
fingerprint powder and our brushes we're
gonna use what we're gonna do is we're
gonna coat the brush with powder so
what's the powder made out of for white
powder it's titanium dioxide with some
sort of wetting agents for this after we
apply powder to it we want to spin off
the excess powder okay anything that's
good it's always better to add powder
than it is to remove powder so we want
to add powder slowly to our surface
while we're dusting we want to look at
the service and we want to use our
oblique lighting also so that's gonna
help us direct where we're gonna brush
we're just going to move it back and
forth on the surface and then once I see
a fingerprint develop I want to then
look at the way the ridge detail is
going and follow that pattern all right
I don't think I have enough powder even
better you're a lot better at this knife
oh I see some good but do you see if
it's is it a whirl is it a loop is an
arch which way are the lines going is it
going a circle okay so now take your
brush and follow that circle and that's
to develop the print a little more oh
yeah it's coming out great so we're done
with dusting let's go on to lift it take
a print packing tape oh yeah I mean it's
specifically designed for finger prints
oh it's not like super like like very
particularly a sticky you'll notice it's
very clear so open it up we should be
able to see right through
so we want to do it one steady Swift
motion like so excellent so what I want
to do first is gonna start my tape
outside of where that print is so I'll
start it over here the next thing I want
to do is create an anchor point I do
that by moving my finger up and down and
then what I want to do is smooth my
finger across the fingerprint if there's
any sort of texture there I want to work
my finger in when I'm done we have a
fingerprint actually got it guys so the
next step now is to take this lift and
put it on to an acetate okay what's an
acetate it's just a piece of plastic
that we're gonna put it on - got it okay
let's make a transfer what we want to do
is put our acetate on a clean surface my
fingerprint is right there so want to
make sure that that gets on the card so
the same way that I lifted it I want to
put it down and then once it's there I'm
gonna rub back and forth and make sure I
get out any sort of air bubbles that may
be there and there we go
my print is now on the acetate now that
you master tape lifting I let's move on
to something more difficult okay I'm
ready so the most ideal service like I
said is something that's smooth or
non-porous but if we have a surface that
isn't smooth that has a texture to it or
is curved it's more difficult in these
situations we want to use a product
called microsil or any sort of casting
type of silicone component okay so the
next step now is the process these
surfaces in this case we have a
light-colored surface so we'll use a
black powder it's a carbon agent and
wetting agent also so we have our powder
and we have two brushes okay we'll take
a look at it with the light and we see
that there's a really nice fingerprint
right there so lightly apply some powder
to it so just just it barely gonna
happen and now if you see a pattern
there follow that arch everything I
think we're good okay great so we get
some more powder for the golf ball yes
try just to move just the tips of the
brush and move it back and forth see
anything appearing any friction Ridge
detail this is a really hard surface huh
it is a hard surface or is there any
like object shape like that they usually
you see besides like doorknobs not this
difficult
I've had occasion to have textured
surfaces that are dimpled like this what
kind of objects
had a base at a crime scene that had a
very textured surface like that and that
if I was to try to lift it with regular
lifting tape it would have done anything
so the next step now is to prepare our
microcell and apply it to our surface so
this is microcell it's a casting
component we use to recover fingerprints
or impressions and difficult surfaces so
I'll do one from one side of the card to
the other and now I'm gonna draw a line
just below it in the hardener and you'll
see it's gonna come out thinner as long
it's the same length that's all that
matters to me makes the blue into the
white and I'm just gonna scoop up some
of this microcell and we're just gonna
spread it over just like you would
spackle a hole all right what kind of
cases have you used this in before
everything from sexual assaults to
homicides
I had a case where someone broke into a
house and they left a tool mark
impression from a screwdriver to break
in so we use that to cast a tool mark
impression so now I'm gonna have you
mixed up your own batch so you can use
this not only for fingerprints you can
use it for other sorts of impressions as
well yes
so how long does it take to drive well
it depends on the environment but within
15-20 minutes it should be dry so let's
take a look at what we got the big
reveal so what I now put this print on
tape like usual or what I just take a
photograph of this where would I go next
with my little print down here so after
we're done recovering this we want to
secure it so that fingerprint doesn't
get destroyed so we'll put it into a
small box send this to the lab they'll
take examination quality photographs of
it and they may have to do other types
of enhancement to it but these look
great like I think you can make an
identification just from these guys so
impressive it really works do you think
it's gonna work no I mean I thought I
was gonna work but it's like it's just
so clear yeah no it's really good
so you're ready for a more difficult
situation let's do it this bottle is
curved which is difficult to begin with
let's make it even more difficult let's
say it rained a night before
okay so fingerprints are comprised
mostly of water the remaining percentage
of fingerprints are mineral salts amino
acids and lipids so if it rained that 98
percent of the fingerprint is gone but
what remains could be the fatty part of
the fingerprint god it's like the oils
that were on my finger right so
sebaceous glands that you have are
secreting oils and there's products
which will react with those lipids and
make them stand out yeah so it's a
suspended solution of a little DM
disulfide that will react with the fats
in your fingerprint so is there any
technique here that I should be aware of
so start the top I'll work your way
across and down okay
and we'll completely coat this in and
you can actually see where it's beating
off you could see that reaction between
the two yeah I can see a fingerprint
right there totally yeah
so what we're seeing is just like water
would beat off of oil
this product is beating off the areas
that we have fingerprints we're looking
for that reaction and when we want to
stop that reaction we want to clean it
with some water so just spray spray
spray
okay wow that's crazy it just stays
right on there how often do you use this
technique so it's good for surfaces that
are wet it also works really well on
greasy surfaces so if I had a crime
scene in a kitchen and there's a layer
of grease on everything if you're trying
to dust it you're just gonna spread that
grease around so what I want you to do
is the same technique we used before to
lift it you're gonna do the same thing
just notice that it's gonna be a little
more difficult ah that's right okay I
think I see it on there a little bit a
little bit okay I think you could have
done better okay well again let's just
clean that off a bit are there
situations where you to hurry out a
crime scene
yeah I mean if this is outside and it's
continually raining and there's no way
that we could field that we may have to
lift it right away take off a car or
something so then we would take this
print and we'd transfer it to a card
would you like draw a picture of the
bottle yeah absolutely we draw a diagram
of the bottle and like circle or draw an
arrow to where we got the print from so
now we'll make it harder on ourselves
what if we have a bloody fingerprint so
we have three different types of
impressions at a crime scene we have
latent payton and plastic Layton is what
we already have developed with the
fingerprint powder Peyton is where it's
impressed in some sort of substance so
blood mud oil a plastic print is
impressed in a soft surface so we're
gonna create some bloody fingerprints on
our drywall and we're gonna use a
chemical to process it to enhance the
detail that could be there so we're
we're gonna get the blood I actually
brought some porous no people are harmed
in there no no one was harmed this was
taken with someone's permission it's
actually been treated so it's very safe
we could actually drink that if we
wanted to it's very cool I just imagine
blood to be warm I guess okay so keep
going across keep going let's do that
let's do one more on this scale what do
you usually see is it like really bloody
like battered usually yeah you can you
can see anywhere in between so you would
think like the bloodier ones are your
better ones but it's usually the lighter
ones that are gonna give us some more
detail so actually if we just look at
them now we may see some rich detail we
may not actually women have more
minutiae the hub
tighter Ridge detail than men so
sometimes it's more difficult to see
woman's fingerprints what about age is
that easier to see like an older
person's print versus I'm seeing a baby
would be really hard versus like someone
who's been only aged yeah absolutely
that's true but your fingerprints don't
change throughout your life if you're a
teller or if you worked in masonry
sometimes you could wear down your
fingerprints all right so I'm gonna do
the same thing how often do you see your
body fingerprints unfortunately a lot
really this is not just a movie thing
it's something you see no yeah but it is
like the best type of evidence that we
can get so if we have the victim's blood
and we have the suspects impression in a
victim's blood it's like a smoking gun
type of evidence it's pretty
incriminating huh
yes all right so now we're gonna apply
leuco crystal violet to our surface so
what is the chemical do a lot of
presumptive blood agents will have
hydrogen peroxide in it and so there's a
mixture of leuco crystal violet with
hydrogen peroxide that catalytic
reaction that we have that hydrogen
peroxide will have with the heme group
and blood it will turn this product
purple to violet for this we're gonna
put on masks also because we don't
really don't wanna breathe this in so
what's the reason for the mask well put
it this way this chemical is gonna turn
blood into islet purple color we don't
want to turn our insides that color
got it yeah it's not carcinogenic but we
still don't want to breathe it in so
we'll cover these areas with filter
paper and then we're just gonna spray
the chemical right on top of it
see that color change immediately
wow it's so bright already we don't see
any areas that are still red through the
filter paper we could lift this up see
how it developed it's so much more clear
so if you could see before we didn't see
a lot of detail on some of these it
start to bring out detail and see even
on some of these lighter ones it
developed it pretty good so do you use
UV light to examine these or do we just
do it under like normal light or use a
flashlight or something like that
yes certain chemicals we use require
different wavelengths of light not so
much with this but with fluorescent
powders certain chemicals like
fluorescein will use a specific
wavelength of light so now would the
next step be to take a photo or would
you bring the tape out again so we would
first photograph it as is so we would
take a close-up macro shot of these
fingerprints before we process them and
then we would photograph them again and
then what we could do is just cut the
surface out and send it to the lab
because there's other steps that they
could do at the lab that we can't do in
the field so after you collect the
fingerprints how are they analyzed what
sorts of databases are you checking them
against when we're done recovering the
fingerprints we create a report for that
and then we send the report with our
fingerprints to an analyst the analyst
will first look at the fingerprints to
first say they're of value or they're
not a value if there's enough points of
identification in there for them to make
an ID on it once they say that's a value
then they'll scan it into the database
so there is the local database and then
there's a state level and then as a
federal database so that's how you
looking prints thank you so much for
showing me